[Music]
hi I'm Isabelle I'm a software engineer
and today we're going to get Cordo set
up on your computer you'll start out by
going to c.org click on get started on
their homepage and download the Cordo
CLI tool in vs code you'll create a new
file and name it whatever you want with
qmd at the end I'd also recommend
downloading the Cordo extension in vs
code it gives you buttons to click uh to
preview your files and syntax
highlighting and a lot of other nice
stuff once we're back in our file we're
going to have to specify a output format
let's start out by just creating an HTML
web page this will be great for
publishing reports um or whatever else
we want to share we're just going to
create a few headings we'll say hello
We'll add some python code and let's
press preview Cordo generates HTML we
see WR in vs code or I can pop it out
and look at it as a local website to
change from a website to a presentation
I Chang the format from HTML to reveal
JS and press preview again